so this is starting to get it's more
than pathetic it's actually starting to
get annoying
republicans and even seemingly some
reporters
continue to try to shame joe biden
and really also his press secretary jenn
saki
under the guise of unity and
bipartisanship
into accepting a tiny package
from republicans on covet relief and
it just seems like groundhog's day at
this point
every day jensaki is having to tell
reporters
no i don't want this tiny package from
republicans
she's rejecting the imposition of this
tiny package
every single day that she takes
questions so let's take
a look at some clips here here is gen
saki explaining
the risk isn't a package that's too big
the risk is that we do a package that's
too small going through
all the trouble of getting something
passed
and then it's too small that's the real
risk and we don't want that
it's an exchange of ideas an opportunity
to do that
this group obviously sent a letter with
some outlines some top lines of of their
concerns and their priorities and he's
happy to have a conversation with them
what this meeting is not is a form for
the president to make or accept an
offer so i think that's important to
convey to all of you
and his view it remains what was stated
in the statement last night but also
what he said on friday which is that
the risk is not that it is too big this
package the risk
is that it is too small and that remains
his view and one he'll certainly express
today then again a few days ago asked
about bipartisanship
why won't joe biden consider a smaller
package why won't she consider a smaller
package democratic leaders on the hill
appear to already be eyeing
reconciliation we heard
uh leader chuck schumer today saying
that they're moving ahead with or
without republicans
does this undermine your calls for
bipartisanship and are you urging them
to give this more time
well for we're all very close to this
here reconciliation and all the
terminology in washington
everybody who's watching may not be
reconciliation is a parliamentary
process it's a way to get legislation
through
it's a way to get relief to the american
people the president wants this to be a
bipartisan package
regardless of the mechanisms republicans
can still vote for a package
even it goes through if even if it goes
through with reconciliation there's no
blood oath anybody signs
this is another good point just because
democrats
might end up going through budget
reconciliation
to pass without to pass the coveted
relief bill
without initial republican support
republicans can still make the call to
vote for
and what i mean by that is republicans
can demand a tiny tiny package
as much as they want and jen sackey can
say i don't want the tiny package joe
biden doesn't want the tiny package
and eventually democrats might say it's
the 1.9 trillion dollar package
just because republicans opposed it
during the the discussion
doesn't mean that after the fact if
that's what they ultimately get to vote
on they can't say you know a lot of my
constituents actually
like this i am better off voting for the
larger package
rather than not because i might have
consequences with my constituents if i
vote against this thing
here's more from this week again about
the size of the package
gen saki is not willing to give any
signal
that joe biden will accept package size
reduction
and i'm glad she's being clear about it
two others on that you said in your
statement that the scale of what must be
done
is large that's bottom line it's 618
billion dollars
considered large by the white house uh
well i think our statement last night
made clear that uh the president
believes that the risk
is not being too going too small but
going
uh going uh not big enough again
with the small packages what if it's too
big
the issue is it being too small and i
have to tell you in a sense
they're already democrats have already
decided instead of doing
2 000 more dollars they want to do 1400
more dollars
which would combine with the 600 from
december
to total 2 000. that's already smaller
than what was promised by joe biden
right around the time of the georgia
elections they've already conceded
uh and i think that this is important
even coming to the table with 1400
instead of 2 000 per person
is already shrinkage for lack of a
better term in terms of the package size
here's another one from yesterday again
reporters
uh playing to republicans who say oh
it's too big is too much money
the president's bottom line is that this
is a package
the risk here as he has said many times
is not going to
too big it is going too small that
continues to be his belief and that's
why he can
he supports uh the efforts by senator
schumer leader schumer
and speaker pelosi to move this package
forward my sense
is that this is not going to stop
anytime soon so as i've said
yesterday pass the larger package
and do it with or without republicans if
republicans
really want to vote no let them say it's
bad
let them vote against and let them
explain to their constituents
why they didn't want to deliver a
package of this size
to them and then constituents can decide
does this person really have
my best interests in mind and when it
comes to the members of the house of
representatives
in under you know what is it at this
point we're talking about 22 months
insane right but in 22 months those
constituents can decide
to either re-elect or not their
representatives
who may reject the 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus package i think that for
democrats this is very much a risk worth
taking
and i would like to see them just say
this is enough joe biden had the meeting
these 10 republicans are obsessed with
tiny packages and that's
all they kept proposing gen saki
rejected the advances of the tiny
package joe biden doesn't it's just time
guys
it's time they've already delayed and
they've already reduced the package size
i hate that this happened but democrats
have
already they sort of negotiated against
themselves and what i mean by that is
joe biden said i support and if ossif
and warnock win
we will immediately send out two
thousand dollar checks uh it didn't
happen immediately and they're only
talking about fourteen hundred
that's the negotiation democrats as as
they often do
negotiating against themselves that's it
no further negotiation
let's move forward pass it via budget
reconciliation
we were there were questions about joe
manchin from the what i've read over the
last 24 hours
joe manchin is going to go for it he
will vote for the package
uh so it's time to do it i would like to
see it done within 24 hours i don't
think that's going to happen maybe 72
maybe 96
let's stop this nonsense let me know
your thoughts about it package size and
all
you can find me on twitter deepakman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid 19 and they're giving my
audience 20 percent off
snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is free
on orders over 150 you can get there by
going to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david